disons mon ancien propriétaire quand
j'étais expulsé je lui avais demandé
plusieurs fois de faire les travaux
parce qu'il y avait des fuites de toi
des fuites de toi d'accord
et en 2019 j'étais obligé d'appeler mon
pied parce que ça a coulé par la bouche
à irration et le comment le pompier m'a
dit
vous pouvez plus rester là d'accord donc
j'ai demandé à mon propriétaire de faire
les travaux il a pas voulu mais j'ai dit
vous payez vous faites pas les travaux
vous faites depuis le
Rizlaine donc c'est là que ça a commencé
c'est comme ça que ça a commencé on
s'est retrouvé à la rue alors
donc vous payez plus
me demande d'inscription la loi a été
pour lui et puis voilà
c'était pas la première fois ça n'était
pas la première fois c'est ça la
première fois
ma femme avant elle percevait la
location adulte handicapée d'accord moi
je perçois 250 euros de retraite
et je touche 860 euros de retraite c'est
ça
ma femme j'ai 900 euros quand elle les a
perdus puisque à 60 ans et 9 mois ils
ont pris des
les comptes du couple et donc on s'est
retrouvés avec une options euros d'un
mois d'un coup
alors vous faisiez quoi dans la vie
alors moi disons je suis originaire le
Bourgogne d'accord il faut faire quoi
dans la vie je travaillais depuis tout
le temps je travaillais en usine
d'accord et vous Gisèle
à ce moment là quand vous faites
expulser vous allez d'abord vous tournez
vers des hôtels j'habite à l'hôtel c'est
ça
que quand j'ai su qu'on avait
l'expulsion
j'avais un malinois que j'ai confié à
une personne
donc le 10 avril j'ai fait une tentative
de suicide parce que je pouvais
plus
que vous arrivez plus à gagner un moment
donné vous baissez les bras
que ça arrive on réfléchit pas parce que
ça vient deux ans que je me battais et
puis à un moment donné
on nous a mis à la Croix Rouge d'accord
la Croix-Rouge nous a mis dans un hôtel
à Vauvert
trois quatre mois après ils nous ont dit
on peut plus payer
on m'a dit vous allez aller à
des jours à Nîmes d'accord
ce nom c'est une association de sans
abris
l'homme qui voulait nous mettre là moi
quand j'ai vu ça j'ai dit non je peux
pas alors ils m'ont dit on va vous
trouver un petit studio
seulement quand on quand je me suis
renseigné et tout fallait pas que je
prenne ma petite chienne
j'ai dit ma femme un traitement oui ça
fait 25 ans qu'on est chez lui par le
même médecin ah ben non vous avez tout
sur lui-même
parce que si c'est pour
tout me casser
la santé de ma femme j'ai pas bougé
donc
la Croix Rouge nous a dit on paye plus
il y a une dame qui a été très gentille
qui habitait derrière l'hôtel quand elle
a su ce qui nous arrivait elle nous a
pris chez elle une dame que vous
connaissiez pas je l'ai connu grâce à ma
boutique
et là
j'ai expliqué elle m'a dit non moi je ne
veux pas que vous alliez à la vous venez
chez moi
seulement cette dame
trois quatre jours avant Noël elle a eu
des sérieux problèmes de santé ce que
j'ai fait j'ai dit on part parce que ça
sentait pas ça pour nous
et les sons ont été des gens super
donc on est parti
chez son frère qui habite la Réunion et
qui nous avait laissé sa maison sur
Générac donc vous êtes parti donc parce
que vous connaissiez son frère en fait
qui est avec elle dans la maison là-bas
ou bien bah disons là cette dame
habitait mauvais d'accord et donc son
frère vous accueilli à la réunion
nous a laissé sa maison
très gentil mais ce qu'il y a c'est que
disons cette maison était il était en
train de tout refaire d'accord il y
avait des fils électriques qui parlait
de partout il y avait des plafonds qui
étaient cassés
moi j'ai eu peur parce que j'ai dit s'il
y a un coup de circuit je dis on est bon
j'ai rappelé la Croix Rouge
et la Croix-Rouge est venue les deux
jeunes de la croix-rouche et sont
monuments
donc ils nous ont mis à l'hôtel César à
Nîmes
d'accord et on a été à l'hôtel de César
à Nîmes
et après là cette chanson sociale de la
comment l'assistante sociale de la croix
au vu de m'a dit je vous ai trouvé un
hébergement
je serai grabaté j'aurais pas toute ma
tête j'aurais dit oui mais pas là ah oui
pourquoi vous fouillez pas aller en
maison
donc là aujourd'hui vous dormez dans
votre voiture
mais maintenant là il y a
un jour on était garé là et un couple de
jeunes est arrivé
j'ai plus peur j'ai dit que si
ils se sont approchés
demain matin vous venez à la maison vous
aurez lu les genoux le repas vous pouvez
mouler et moi et la lame de la femme de
cet homme m'a dit je vous la vote là
je vous dis que c'est les prénoms
j'en ai pleuré parce que ça m'a beaucoup
touché et donc vous y êtes allé
vous êtes allés
qui a fait de façon à ce que ça passe
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est ça
d'accord bravo Benjamin et Patricia
alors et donc là vous êtes allés chez
eux comment vous êtes allés chez eux
à comprendre c'est que Monsieur le Maire
de Vauvert
quand on a été il y avait eu France de
Gard Lozère le maire de Maubert on nous
a reçu avec les gens et il me fait vous
avez demandé que vos mères chez Monsieur
maire vous êtes à menteur j'ai pas
demandé que mon père
60 km parce que comme notre fils est
décédée je voulais pas partir trop loin
pas seulement ne lâche que j'ai je peux
plus me permettre de faire 4500 km vous
en êtes aujourd'hui alors comment
aujourd'hui vous en êtes où
dans la voiture
mais non parce que il y a
m'a contacté d'accord et il m'a dit
Alain je lui veux vous voir et vous
connaissez pas
il a pris il vous a plu
il vous a retrouvé il vous a retrouvé
[Musique]
il m'a dit on va tout faire pour vous
parce que c'est pas normal même que vous
ayez fait des erreurs c'est pas normal
qu'à votre âge on vous laisse dans la
rue
et maître color a été très gentil avec
nous très sympathique et vous alors et
donc vous en êtes aujourd'hui et donc là
on a été trois jours à l'hôtel à
Saint-Gilles justement pour pas qu'on
dorme dans la voiture
et il y a des gens
pendant quelque chose donc là donc là
vous allez avoir un manga d'oie je vais
avoir un bungalow pendant 15 jours donc
je vais normalement je vais y aller ce
soir d'accord ce soir vous êtes à
l'hôtel c'est pour nous voilà à l'hôtel
comme je suis ici je peux pas à l'hôtel
à ce soir si vous êtes à l'hôtel
des gens douteux ah oui c'est ça parce
que c'est ce qu'il a dit c'est ce qu'il
a dit
exactement et qui s'appuie sur le fait
qu'une trois expulsions pour dire
finalement ils ont un peu dans son
esprit ils ont un peu chercher ce qu'il
leur arrive ce qui est scandaleux ils
vous reproche un peu ça donc c'est très
bien qui est des initiatives parce que
effectivement vous devez être dans un
rayon proche il faut le rappeler
tous les gens ont le même problème que
moi c'est des gens douteux c'est ce que
dit le maire c'est ce que sous-entend le
maire qui n'a rien fait pour vous il dit
voilà il dit vous avez été beaucoup
voilà vous avez de ce qui dit voilà vous
avez refuser la maison de retraite vous
avez refusé le studio
vous avez refusé beaucoup de choses
qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez au
maître Homer de Vauvert est-ce que le
maire le match posé de logement
parce que comme j'ai dit si on me
propose d'aller au n'importe où
dans un rayon de 60 km je le prends
parce que moi je veux un poids pour ma
femme ma petite chienne est pour moi
qu'on puisse parce que mon épouse a
quand même été opéré du dos
et de leur voiture c'était pas mal donc
là on a ce soir l'hôtel après 15 jours
en magasin et après
il va vous aider
c'est grâce à lui que vous avez le
bungalow voilà d'accord très bien donc
d'accord donc là vous avez 15 jours de
bungalow déjà en plus de ça j'ai
contacté une association qui s'appelle
l'espélino
des logements
de commencer à prendre des HLM
mais seulement maintenant on me dit on
me connaît pas
et pourtant j'ai la preuve puisque le
premier juin j'ai eu affaire à une âme
de l'expérido le lui a eu un père à une
dame de l'espélidau et là il dans ma
poche et un rendez-vous comme quoi j'ai
rendez-vous le 28 encore avec cette dent
d'accord alors
là grâce à ce soir encore j'espère que
vous allez avoir d'autres propositions
vraiment Alain Gisèle là donc là vous
êtes tranquille pour pour 15 jours pour
l'instant voilà d'accord donc on va
essayer de faire le maximum pour que
vous soyez tranquille est-ce que tout le
temps plus de ça moi
bien sûr que je pouvais plus
son âge où il y a donné 50 €
et maintenant
c'est l'arrivée ça je comprends pas
pourquoi la réglisse
je ne comprends pas pourquoi il a aimé
ça la paix puisque elle a jamais
travaillé de sa vie et on lui donne 172
euros par mois ok bon
qui font tout pour récupérer leurs
enfants et moi j'ai bien dit je ne veux
pas vous créer de problèmes vos enfants
sont primordial par rapport